For me.
A movie that's brilliantly combines both
cinematic storytelling and social
critique is David fincher's,
the social network,
the movie centers around it's Mark
Zuckerburg plate by Jesse Eisenberg and
the creation of facebook.
Now the work of director David fincher
is known for dark central teams of
mccarver firelands crime broken
psychology.
His major characters range from
emotionally closed off to depressed and
schizophrenia to complete psychopathic
serial killer.
She begged for her life.
She begged for her life set up and for
the life of the baby inside of her.
Knowing this,
I think it's easy to predict the social
network is not going to be your average
run of the mill young struggling
entrepreneur success story.
This already becomes clear in the
soundtrack during the opening credits.
This piece of music that's returns
multiple times in the movie combines the
saft piano tune in an uneasy tension
creating file in behind it.
The score created by Trent reznor
already illustrates the major teams of
the movie named Leah,
broken loneliness and a seating anger,
a thirst for power underneath it.
So the question is,
what does the social network really
about?
Let's get started.
The narrative of the movie doesn't rely
so much on the creation of facebook to
be a good story.
The central teams can also be found in
many important stories throughout
history.
It's the right off the film.
Aaron Sorkin says it's not a movie about
facebook.
It's a movie set against the backdrop of
facebook,
but really it's the themes and this move
yours.
All the storytelling itself,
the as he calls them Shakespearean teams
that and is talking about are things
like power,
hunger,
social class section,
love,
friendship,
loyalty and betrayal only friend.
Yeah.
These teams are embedded in a plot that
focuses on the relationships that Mark
Hass and destroys during the creation of
facebook.
The narrative for stores from the
prospective of two hearings,
one buyer market sued by his former best
friend and another where Marc sued by
its competitors.
The opening act and all the seats that's
folks on the creation of facebook are in
fact flashbacks solely ever feeling the
reasons mark it suits for fucking over
as best friends potentially stealing the
idea of facebook from this competition.
Do you see any of your code on facebook?
I,
I use any of your coke,
she stole our whole Goddamn idea.
match.com for hiring and you know,
you really don't need it forensics team
to get to the bottom of this and if you
guys were the inventors of facebook ad
to Facebook,
it is certainly true that the film's
plot can't stand on its own as a strong
end entertaining story.
Yet in my opinion,
to see the creation of facebook and as
just the background of the story does
not do the film justice.
Facebook as the biggest and most
powerful social let's book in the world
is a fascinating subject for media
scholars and a lot of questions and
critique and it's working.
Yes,
found within the plot dialogue and
especially the character's personality,
you have part of my attention,
you have a minimum amount.
The rest of my attention is back at the
offices of facebook where my colleagues
and I are doing things that no one in
this room including and especially your
clients or intellectually or creatively
capable of doing.
I want to look at this from a couple of
different perspectives,
building it up and important,
but first I have to say many scholars
have found positive aspects of facebook.
Since you know the nature of finches
work,
we are mainly discussing critique on
facebook,
which of course it's very important
critique,
but it does mean facebook is something
evil that only as negative for
infection.
Social life for example,
if facebook has had very positive
effects on weak social ties,
meaning that week social relations such
as holiday friends,
which are problematic because of this.
This can stay active.
Thanks you facebook.
Now back to the fields critique or
facebook.
A major issue of the recent years is
incident Boudin and the nature of the
comment sections,
discussions on social and political
issues of quickly escalate right for
comments on mine for victims of
bullying.
Often in high school,
the bullying continues to facebook when
they come home and the social network,
when mark gets broken up with he blocks
hatefully about his ex girlfriend when
he tries to apologize.
She perfectly explains the nature of
Internet bullying in a couple of lights.
The Internet's not written in Pencil
mark.
It's written in ink and you published an
eric all Brits and Bitch right before
you made some ignorant crack about my
family's name,
my bra size,
and then graded women based on their
hotness.
You write your snipe bullshit from a
dark room because that's what the angry
do nowadays,
June,
the beginning of the film off to Moscow
from,
so I'll put him in the opening scene.
Mark also creates a website where you
can rank the university's girls in the
hotness against each other.
The scene intercut,
secretion and immediate popularity of
this website against a fraternity party
where girls are brought in on a bus and
are clearly sexually objectified.
This illustrates beautifully how the
sexual objectification of girls and
college is digitalized,
creating a sort of power shift from the
fraternity,
popular jocks to show called nerds.
That's created the website at the end of
the scene.
Even the jokes at the party are clicking
on the website.
This is the key of the film's critiques.
It's concentrating on the digitalization
of the social experience of college,
not only in the front birds but also the
hard parts such as social hierarchy,
exclusion and rejection
and talking about taking the entire
social experience of college and putting
it online.
I can't feel my legs.
I know I'm totally psyched about this
too,
but pardot.
Yeah,
it would be exclusive.
See in a world where social structure
was everything,
that was the thing.
This brings us back to the original
themes of sadness and anger in the
opening credits soundtrack and we see
facebook as a digitalization of social
life.
We have to look at the social life of
its creator already in the opening scene
of the film,
much becomes clear about mark's
motivations is obsessed with getting
into a final club because of the social
standing it would provide,
but because of this he completely misses
out that his girlfriend is trying to
have real conversation with him and he
has condescending to her social
conditioning.
You want to tell you that?
I think you might want to be a little
more supportive.
I get in,
I will be taking you to the events and
the gatherings and they'll be meeting a
lot of people you wouldn't normally get
to
me.
Mark solution to his inability and anger
about not being able to create authentic
social relations is to become obsessed
with improving his position in the
social hierarchy of college.
GM tyree.
In his paper,
the dislike button says one of the
problems of facebook is that it's like
the Ikea of the mind.
We riding users who generate an endless
flow of good news and consumable tidbits
of their own interiority,
stream of folks' consciousness.
That next one seem more cheerful,
more entrepreneurial,
and more boring than anyone,
but someone ever wants to be friend.
This is what we see in Mark's
personality.
Instead of trying to mend broken
relations,
the solution,
it's a train peer,
more successful hoping that people were
accepting,
hey,
that was great.
That was the right thing.
You apologize.
At the end of the movie,
Marcus destroying every authentic social
relationship,
living more in the social fantasy of
facebook.
Why it in?
As Justin Timberlake's character says,
yeah,
mark's former best friend.
Still try it one more time to finally
break to thus revealing a desire for
intimacy for a messy but real human
contact.
Yes.
You wish your 24 million new shares of
stock.
You were told that if you investors come
up on your shares diluted,
how much were his,
you signed the papers you sent me.
You're going to blame me because here
were the business head of the company
and you made a bad business deal with
your own company.
It's going to be like I'm not a part of
facebook won't be like you're not a part
of facebook.
You're not a part of facebook names on
the masthead.
You might want to check again cause I
froze the account.
I think we were going to let you parade
around in your ridiculous suits
pretending you were running the second
broad.
Is it the cleaners along with my hoodie
and my fuck you flip flops.
You pretentious Douche back securities
here.
You'll be leaving now not signing those
papers.
We will get the signature.
Tell me this isn't about me Kenny.
It's the phoenix.
I knew you did it.
You planted the story about the chicken.
I didn't find the story.
What's he talking about?
The accused of animal cruelty.
Seriously,
what the hell is the chicken and all
back what?
You hated the off,
so they identified me as a cofounder of
facebook,
which I am,
you bet our lawyer up asshole because
I'm not coming back for 30% I'm coming
back for everything.
In the end.
This film is just an interpretation of
the events and great as a facebook,
he had a gift,
some strong critique on facebook backers
in a wild story off power,
friendship and betrayal suggesting in
the end that the most successful social
network in the world was created by
someone who else just trying to fit in.
Hey guys,
thanks for watching and the social
network is one of my favorite movies and
it was a lot of fun to analyze it.
I still think there's a lot more in this
movie that can be explored,
so I would encourage you to watch it to
yourself.
The next video will be about apocalypse
now and a duality for if you have any
ideas or thoughts on this analyze.
I would encourage you to comment in the
comment section below,
and of course,
if you liked the video,
please subscribe and we will see you
next time.